the invention of this idea that you
referred to that disparity means that
there's discrimination going on it is
completely ahistorical and
non-scientific in every way most people
don't know what disper impa was if they
did know what disper impa was they would
probably be horrified by it if you just
had quarters like it might even be
better because you could at least give a
test and just take the best people but
you can't but the law is such that you
can't do that because you have to have
the facade of uh equal treatment and so
you can't just have quotas so you just
what you what you is you just get rid of
the standards
completely Richard so you wrote this
book the origins of woke uh it's a
subject that as you know and as our
audience know we've been talking about
for a long time you have a different
take on it actually to quite a lot of
people before we get into the origins of
woke the one thing that everyone uh who
hates people talking about woke claims
is that no one can Define what woke is
you actually start by defining what woke
is what is woke yeah I mean yeah this
this is a sort of a strange thing to
pretend like you know we can't Define
this thing and sometimes people can't
because people don't think about
definitions well but I you know I think
that you know we all sort of have the
idea we know something is woke we know
Ibraham kendi is woke and uh you know
the Southern Baptist convention is is
less so right I mean we all sort of have
this understanding um and so I think you
know I have a definition that I think
covers most of it um it's not too broad
it's not too narrow it's the idea that
disparities are caused by discrimination
they could be past or present so if
blacks do less well on a test than
whites or you know there's a difference
in arrest R between races or men earn
more money than women that's due to
discrimination past or present you know
it it has to be white versus non-white
or men versus women that we don't care
about other kinds of disparities um you
need speech restrictions um in the
interest of overcoming these disparities
so you have to get rid of you know
stereotypes people you know having you
know problematic thoughts about uh
origins of disparities that are not
discrimination uh and then there's a
bureaucracy that sort of you know tries
to overcome disparities and also enfor
enforces the speech code so this is
everything from uh you know the Dei
offices and universities uh to you know
like nonprofits and government
institutions that are trying to close
various racial uh and gender gaps so the
three ideas of disparities equals
discrimination speech codes and the
bureaucracy in force to these ideas I
think is the core of wokeness and how we
talk about it in modern society very
interesting and particularly with
reference to the bureaucracy this is why
I mentioned you have a an original way
of looking at where this comes from tell
us where you think Wess comes from yeah
I mean so you know the Civil Rights
Movement was sort of like this moral and
legal and cultural tsunami that washed
over the United States in the mid 1960s
um and you know it did some things that
everyone agrees you know most everyone
agrees is good now like eliminate uh
explicit discrimination State sanction
discrimination um even in the private
sector uh you know told people they
couldn't discriminate based on race and
sex what you know so people that's sort
of the standard history and that's that
part is true um at the same time it sort
of empowered a bureaucratic class to
look for discrimination um wherever they
could find it and the definition of sort
of discrimination and what counts as
discrimination um expanded and it was
given the force of law uh and so a lot
of these things that you see as wokeness
what people would call wokeness in the
last 10 15 years um have been part of
American law since the real sometimes in
some cases since the early 1970s uh so
the idea that if you take a test and
whites do better than blacks you it's
always funny to me that people you know
Twitter they they sort of treat it like
it's a new idea that no one ever thought
it before no it's been law of the United
States since 1971 right we've had two
three generations of this being the law
of the land that if you give tests you
know you better be careful or if police
arrest one group more the other now we
still have disparities and we still have
tests and we still have police arresting
people right but it's always sort of
there's always sort of attention
in the all the rules that we have for
like having a society because literally
everything you do that's meritocratic or
that tries to keep order has a dispert
impact based on race based on sex or
whatever and so like it sort of goes
through waves where some of the stuff
sometimes is stuff becomes more
prominent sometimes less uh but it's
part of it's just very very deep in sort
of the legal fabric of American society
right now and I think that the a lot of
the cultural sort of you know the these
corporations like paying you know
hundreds of thousands or millions of
dollars um for these uh you know HR and
Dei Consultants I think a lot of it is
clearly Downstream of the law which I
try to show uh you know just try to show
sort of Step by Step In the book The
History of how that happened and Richard
do you think because there's always
going to be people who say you know this
is a conspiracy this has been put
together by whoever it may be do you
think it is or do you think that there
these were well-intentioned people as it
were uh you know it depends on sort of
what level you're you know you're
talking about um you know there's all
you know the sort of civil rights
movement always had a sort of communist
component even them you might say that
they're well you know well-intentioned
they they just think communism is a good
thing um but you know there was always
sort of that there was sort of sort of
that Wing um but then the people who
actually made the decisions that really
embedded wokeness and law you can you
know you could look them up and they
were in many cases sort of mainstream
Democrats Center left um you know judges
they were you they didn't want to withow
capitalism or get rid of the system you
know they generally they genuinely
thought I think every generation
probably believed like okay we need yeah
until recently I think I think like it's
been going on so long but I think I
think that like the earliest Generations
that sort of you know uh got the ball
rolling here um did think that you know
you would have affirmative action for a
generation or you would have make the
police less racist for a generation or
20 years or whatever and then you would
move on um it didn't work out like that
and you know and even like Richard Nixon
who I cover in the not a leftist not a
communist not trying to you know uh you
know bring down the white race or
anything like that you know he was he
himself was sort of caught up in this in
the early days of the civil rights in
the Civil Rights era um you know and
then eventually I think when sort of all
that stuff was discredited by that time
it just became the status quo um it
became if you wanted to get rid of
affirmative action if you wanted to get
rid of disper impact you were seen as
this you know big racist and why were
you thinking about these things and
nobody did think much about these things
for a while until recently I think when
sort of the great awokening took off and
this stuff became so in everyone's face
that like there was no no choice but to
talk about it um so yeah I mean I think
it's you know my my worldview on this is
more unintended consequences and uh
bureaucratic politics that it is some
kind of you know conspiracy theory to to
bring Society down or something like
that because it to me this seems very
much like the law of unintended
consequences that you you implement
something and then 10 or 20 years down
the line it doesn't matter how talented
you are as a legislator and how smart
you are nobody can look into the future
and what you think that you're doing at
this particular
moment I
mean what do you have to go on but an
educated guess yeah yeah and you know
one thing like Thomas Soul points out in
some of his books is that uh racial
preferences are pretty standard in
diverse societies you know all over the
world um and so like you know there's
not you don't have to explain it there
was something in American ideology or
somebody did that you know I think that
there's sort of been a democracy with
racial disparities you sort of get this
stuff um you know naturally and you know
it's the America maybe was a little bit
more resistance to it because of its
Constitution and its founding um but
yeah you know a lot you know a lot of
the the sort of the and the sort of
Direction I it took which I cover in the
book like why do we care so much about
you know female sports and uh you know
in colleges um I don't think we do
anymore Richard yes yeah we well we've
found a little bit of a Twist where the
right wi position has become you know
protect women's sports it's a funny
thing where it's like you know it's just
like people don't really know the
history here and they're just sort of
you know flip-flopping their uh their
positions uh but yeah you know the I
think the you know the the American
version of this is very very you know
intimately related with our
laws um so Richard let as somebody who
doesn't know a great deal about American
law and certainly you know by state as
well can you give some examples to
illustrate your case what exactly give
some specific examples for exactly what
is actually going on here yeah sure uh
so you know there first of all there's
the disperate impact Doctrine so in 1971
the Supreme Court ruled that under
affirmative under uh I'm sorry under the
um uh Civil Rights Act the
Discrimination did not just mean I have
a job where I you know don't want black
people to be hired or or something like
that basically anything you did could
that had a desperate impact means that
one group did better than the other and
it's it's it's I'm not exaggerating and
saying it could be literally anything it
could be a policy that says if you have
a criminal record uh I'm not going to
hire you it could be a tardiness policy
all of this stuff has been sort of
litigated or debated at some point it
becomes problematic from a legal
perspective you have to show a business
necessity so the it's not necessarily
illegal but the burden of proof becomes
on you to the employer uh to show that
like this is necessary you could
potentially be suit over it so that's
one that's a disperate impact Doctrine
that's pretty much the entire private
sector that's all government hiring um
you also have affirmative action in
Government Contracting where basically
you know everything in American law they
deny that there's quotas and it's all
done in the name of um uh it's all done
in the name of equal opportunity um but
if you have a contract with the
government and a lot of corporate
America does uh you have to basically
give them numbers on the race of the sex
uh of the people in your Workforce and
then if one group is under represented
you have to sort of submit plans uh in
how to uh how to address that um you
also have sort of these like harassment
laws where like you know if men want to
you know if if you know you make a group
uncomfortable based on their race or
their sex you know before the 1960s This
was um this was settled by you know the
private sector you didn't like the job
you would you got a you got a new job
even in the first decades after the
Civil Rights Act people didn't interpret
it as okay like you have to you as an
employer have to police the speech of
your employees to make sure that the men
you know don't be too aggressive hitting
on the women or whatever that was really
an innovation in the 1980s so a lot of
the speech codes um came out of that
came out of the idea that like you as an
employer became sort of the babysitter
for your population to predict Some
People based on their group identities
um and then there's all this stuff about
you know colleges colleges is their you
know it's their own category a lot of
these things that people think are
organic to the university they come from
the Federal government so like when they
used to have those Title Nine kangaroo
courts when men were accused of sexual
assault in a lot of cases that was the
Obama Administration you may know the
history because this was covered well in
the press that you know they would come
in and they would say okay you know
you're you're you're violating the Civil
Rights Act if you're not taking rape
seriously enough what is taking rape and
sexual assault seriously enough mean it
means not giving any due process to the
men and hiring all these feminist title
line coordinators and letting them
basically remake your University right
uh so it's you know there's there's all
these doctrines and all these sort of
legal and you know the point is not just
to sort of explain to people how this
happened which you know is interesting
and important enough uh part of the
point is also to tell people like well
you know here's how it happened and
there's actually something you can do
about it because it's just it's just
laws it's just executive orders judicial
decisions you know legislation the way
this stuff was uh implemented it can
also be undone the same way well before
we get to undoing it or or changing the
way that uh the structure of it is uh
how do you incorporate the impact of
social media and the internet in the
cultural Dimension because what you're
really talking about is the legislative
and institutional implementation of
wokeness but I think we'd all agree that
in the last decade or so since the
emergence of social media culturally the
ideas of wokeness have really taken off
uh fueled by social media certainly in
my opinion uh how do you how do you
think about that dimension of it yeah so
my friend Zack Goldberg has written
about the great a Woka dig um and he has
all those charts showing that you know
these terms like systemic racism and so
forth go through the roof around 2011 I
don't think it's a coincidence that it
uh 2011 was around the time that Twitter
became prominent um and I don't think
it's a coincidence that as soon as Elon
Musk bought Twitter you know within uh
the first year of that happening there
were all these stories in the media
about oh wow conservative boycuts are
suddenly working you know before that
conservative boycots if you didn't like
a company doing some kind of trans
initiative you know that was considered
hate speech and you're you know the
algorithm either uh repressed your
speech or you know you were bad
completely um and so yeah there is room
you know in the theory you know in this
world for sort of technological forces
and cultural uh factors and I I do think
that the internet and social media you
know was important starting around 20110
2011 uh at the same time a lot of these
ideas that sort of became more like
prominent in the you know in the minds
of the public they were you know they
they were there before it's just like
liberals were sort of they had more
cognitive distance they were a little
bit more ashamed of them there were
there was I think a little bit more of a
sort of uh
compartmentalizing right so like when
ibram kendi comes along and says uh you
know we have we need a department of
anti-racism which says that anything
that has a disperate impact on blacks
relative to whites uh needs to be uh you
know needs to be investigated or bad um
you know that's been that's been
something close to that has been the has
been the law for 50 years just people
started to notice it because Ibraham
kendi sort of you know he came and he
made it explicit and like people stopped
being ashamed of it and they brought
them and they gave speeches and they
said okay let's just say this stuff out
loud uh but like every corporation and
every government department has been
operating on this basis has been
counting people according to race and
sex and like you know doing soft quotas
and making sure you know that you know
policing the speech of employees they've
been doing that for decades and decades
um so you know there is there is H
something new with social media there is
also a continuation um that I think
people don't realize it's all been there
well I I what what I mean though is I
think it's like I I don't know I'm
probably a bit older than you in when I
was a young guy and I was kind of on the
what you call liberal I would we in this
country call left I don't remember
people
pretending that you can change your sex
by means of words un questionably yeah
yeah yeah please yeah I mean I've read
about this a little bit yeah I I think
there's a I say on Race you could look
like a conversation from 2020 in the US
and a conversation from 1975 and they're
almost the exact same thing I mean even
like the police the riots like some you
know the 19 late 1960s some some you
know gang bangger would career criminal
would get killed by the cops there'd be
these riots some people would come out
and say Law and Order and some people
would come out and say no no we got to
get at the root causes we got to you
know stop racism to prevent this 1970
2020 pretty much you know the exact same
thing on sex there's a little bit of
development there's this you know idea
that women you know should be just like
accommoda in work then it becomes you
know women are oppressed class uh
homosexuality and transgenderism here I
mean I think that you're right there
have been it has been revolutionary I
mean I'm I'm I'm also old enough to
remember um when you know being gay was
you know in high school was we had one
or two gay people and like everyone
would be like ew get away from me this
is the most disgusting thing in the
world uh right um you know 10 years
later you know we start legalizing gay
marriage a few years later we have uh uh
you know we have um uh this new um uh
you know gender identity idea um and uh
yeah you're ABS you're absolutely right
I don't think I don't think civil rights
law explains a it's a little bit I mean
there Leo up here at a uh guy at the
Manhattan Institute has been doing some
work about how some of the anti-bullying
initiatives um coming from the federal
government might have made an impact
here um but it's it's it's not as easy
to trace with race and sex so I I do
think you know I agree with you that if
you know the the gender identity stuff
is something something quite new yeah I
I I wasn't trying to explore that
difference in in opinion just for the
sake of it it just seems to me that as
we move on to talking about how to
address some of this you're probably in
a harder place to do it because you now
have social media where a lot of even
crazier ideas have become embedded in
the public Consciousness so when you're
talking about repealing certain
legislation or revoking executive orders
or whatever there's now a significant
body of the public certainly the the
chattering public on social media who
are just like you know I can't believe
you're even considering this yeah but
it's it's it's a double-edged sword
because there's also um you know I
document the sort of the evolution of
conservatives and the Republican party
over the time too and there's also been
a sort of conservative media ecosystem
um that has sort of uh you know come
around and if sort of if you look at the
parties over the last 30 years the trend
is polarization on every almost every
issue the left becomes more left and the
right becomes more universally
right-wing um so I think that like it's
true it's harder than ever to convince
liberals of this stuff it's easier than
ever to convince conservatives of the
stuff and get the message out there and
show them how absurd it is um so on that
I think it's actually good because you
know you just have you just have to
convince some people who are in power
some of the time uh in order to do this
stuff and it's also very damaging to the
economy Richard because if you think if
you run a construction company most
women don't want to work in construction
yeah so I mean what what are you going
to do with that construction is sexist
mate yeah but but so so what can you do
is Construction Company you know the the
how many women are you going to go start
trolling the bars looking for women and
asking if they want a job in
construction they do that with women's
sports too yeah you're right they do
that with women's sports too and like uh
you know like rowing like for examp
because you know not many women want to
participate in sports as men so they put
up these rowing programs um and Rowing
is a great sport because it requires
tons and tons of people so you just get
as many women as possible and you're
like okay you're all rowers and I
remember when I was at UCLA I knew this
girl who would like that you know they
were just they were filling bodies like
a girl would join for two weeks she'd
recruit her friends they join for two
weeks okay I don't want to be a freaking
rower you know that's not what little
girls grow up you know dream of doing
but they're they'll just take anybody
they'll put them on the team they've got
to make the numbers work I mean you're
right there is this is like a huge tax
on like every part of society and then
it's just like it's you know it's also a
tax in the sense of like you can't have
standards like if you just had quotas
like it might even be better because you
can um you can at least give a test and
just take the best people but you can't
but the law is such that you can't do
that because you have to have the facade
of uh equal treatment um and so you
can't just have quotas so you just what
you what you do is you just get rid of
the standards completely and then hope
the numbers work out it's really it's
really a sort of a a twisted way to run
a country I mean it's sort of amazing
it's amazing at all but there's also
hypocrisy there because nobody looks at
the 100 meters final and goes you know
what we need some more white guys here
you know I mean I'm sure there's some
people do but they were kind of a
minority I was looking at the New York
City marathon yeah I tweeted about that
a couple days ago I mean it was like the
top 20 like or something like that like
18 were from East African descent um and
they were like East Africans from East
Africa and some of them were from
America and some of them were from uh
Western Europe and they were all
happened to be from Somalia or Kenya or
Ethiopia and not even remarked upon I
mean you look at the uh you look at the
New York Times with they reporting on
the New York City marathon yeah just
nothing we ignore race in that situation
I guess it's just the best people won
and
yeah do you think we're we're ever going
to get past the idea because Thomas Soul
who I'm a huge fan of you know this is
one of the things he's been talking
about for decades now the invention of
this idea that you referred to that
disparity means that there's
discrimination going on it is completely
ahistorical and nonscientific in every
way yet when I talk to people in in the
United States in particular cuz it's
less embedded actually here in the UK
okay uh I remember I was flying to Miami
and I was sitting next to a guy who
turned out to be a pilot for the airline
that I was sitting in it was very smart
guy he was a black guy and when we were
talking about what was happening in
Florida he said well I'm an independent
but you know Des santis is anti-woke so
I don't like him and we got into a big
conversation about it and one of the
things he was saying is this very simple
idea and like again I emphasize he was a
smart guy right but here he he was like
look the statistics show
that the number of black airline pilots
does not correspond to the percentage of
the black population of the United
States that means there's discrimination
and I'd like to think I'm a reasonably
persuasive guy I tried every which way I
approached her from 100 different angles
the poor guy was stuck next to me for
about three hours I know how he feels
Richard I couldn't get it I could not
get past the idea with him to him it's
just like disparity dis discrimination I
could not find a way through so it's
just so embedded with many people now
yeah I mean in the American context is
very interesting because yeah I mean it
is there is a lot of historical guilt
about the situation of black Americans I
don't think people like nobody thinks
that Asians doing better than on whites
than whites on Tess is discrimination or
Asians being uh arrested less even
Hispanics and Latinos you know like
you'll hear the but it's not you know
you don't see a lot of New York or
Washington Post uh stories about you
know too few Hispanic Pilots I mean
sometimes you do but it's usually piggy
bagging off the black experience so
you're you're you're right it's it's
it's an American specific idea but it's
also an American black specific idea
just because we have sort of all this
racial baggage uh from our history that
just sort of shuts off our braids
whatever we think of the black issue and
then that becomes transferred like when
we think about Hispanics when we think
about women we have this template um
that we sort of just are so so sort of
uh emotionally Salient right uh that it
becomes sort of the way we think about
everything well that's interesting
because this guy was actually not
africanamerican as you like to say he
was um from the Caribbean and he'd moved
to the us as a as a te which is
interesting because the people in
Caribbean from the Caribbean do
relatively well in the United States so
you think if there was discrimination
right they would see that that's the
problem but that's often the case I mean
Eric Holder you know a very leftwing uh
attorney general under Obama also of
Caribbean descent right so often they
they come the Caribbean you know the
blacks from the Caribbean succeed and
but then they assimilate into the
ideology that says you know black people
can't succeed in America it's very well
what was interesting as well is when I
sort of did get him to see that there
are context in which you can't just
automatically assume discrimination
because uh someone is not as represented
as they are in the general population he
then pivoted to well yes but the company
provides a better service if it's
representative of the population which I
thought was an interesting argument
because I I I don't know that there's
any evidence for that I mean especially
for Pilots like for teachers or police
you hear that sometimes right it sort of
makes sense a little bit but you know do
you know how do you do you pay attention
to the race of your pilot do you feel
safer with their of your race it's it's
in that context yeah it's a very odd
argument so given that historical um
guilt and uh history that is awful in in
the United States let's let's be clear
about that right
um how does that ever get healed is
there a way to overcome that is there a
way to heal that is there a way for you
know people talk about reparations and
it seems like a very crazy idea just
because you'd struggle to implement it
and blah blah blah blah blah but is
there a way that the United States is
ever going to overcome the fact that you
know it was a country that used slavery
in in for a long time and then
discriminated against people who were
descendants of slaves yeah I mean in
like you know sort of these you know in
trial Society sometimes you'll just have
like blood money right something bad
will happen and one group will just pay
off the other the point of that and the
benefit of that is that that that's it
it wipes the Slate clean right um so if
there was some way to just you know have
a you know cut a check um you know we
can't bankrupt ourselves but you know
something you're already bankrupt so
we're already bankrupt right you know
very very theoretically well I mean you
do see this reparations movement and you
know you never see them say that you
never see them say okay we've calculated
you know 50,000 per person or something
you know usually it's much bigger than
that it's some ridiculous number but
it's never like okay no affirmative
action no disper him back no no none of
we never talk about race we can't
complain about racism ever again um if
it was something like that there could
be some kind of basis for a conversation
right but it's all it's always just more
of the same it's you do reparations and
then you have everything else remain the
same and continue to guilt people um and
so yeah if we did if we did have to do
some kind of healing I would prefer a
one-time payment rather than 200 years
from now we're still talking about
littering laws are racist because you
know black people you know get get cited
for them more than white people or you
know Airline you know the airlines are
racist or whatever um yeah it's just
it's just very very hard because I think
that there's you know I I think there's
an understanding even among they they
don't they know it won't fix it they
know there are problems in the black
community you know they know that one
group has you know 70% out of woodlock
births and another group has you know
30% out of woodlock births you know that
there's going to be dispar you could
give people a check that's not going to
that's not going to fix that right and
so I think they even understand that so
it's it's just a matter of you know it's
just a matter of sort of this Perman
this idea of sort of permanent
revolution um and you know conservatives
I think you know some conservatives
might be open to onetime reparations
payment but they see what's going on and
they say yeah of course we're just this
is just another another program and
won't do anything damp and anything else
yeah I I think that's a very good point
because the reality is is these
arguments
a lot of the time they're not based in
fact they're based in emotion and when
someone is emotional it's very difficult
to rationalize with them and go well
look what is it that you actually want
what is it that you want to achieve what
is it that you want from this particular
discussion because or they want to feel
better or they want to win or whatever
it may be and that's very very difficult
to deal with yeah yeah that that's right
I think yeah people just sort of they
need a you know sort of a um look
there's a you have I think you have to
tell people a different story you could
tell people that story which is true
that black people were enslaved and
mistreated for much of American history
and and that's fine um at the same time
you have to tell people that you know
which is just as true that America has
been you know a you know a remarkable
you know engine of sort of uh human
well-being bettering of all Races
including black people in America you
know there's a population of 30
something like 35 40 million black
Americans who have a higher standard of
living than black people in any part of
any other part of the world World um and
you know like every other group comes
here and does and does pretty well and
we should be thankful for that right we
should be thankful in the end that like
as bad as it was in the past we ended up
in a pretty good place from a historical
perspective um and you know I I don't
know I think there's just sort of
there's such a tendency to compare to
you know or to obsess about um you know
past mistreatment or disparities between
groups that it's hard to get there um
but yeah you're right I mean just like
sort of fixing the civil rights laws I
think is part of it can make this stuff
less Salient and at least give them less
political power but as far as sort of
the emotional baggage we have um here
that sort of envelops everything in
society you know that's a much harder
question and sort of a larger project to
deal with well let's talk about fixing
the civil rights laws I mean I I I
wonder whether I agree with you that
that would give them less alence I my
sense based on what we've observed in
recent years of American politics purely
is in Outsider is um and this is kind of
the point I was making earlier to you is
every time conservatives or the right
attempts to deal with some of these
issues everyone freaks out massively and
we saw this with Donald Trump where
essentially his ability to do many of
the things that uh he was trying to do
was impeded by the fact that anytime he
you know took a breath the media lost
their share and then you know he was
evil blah blah blah blah blah and then
he ended up not doing uh many of the
things that he promised to do but tell
us about uh fixing the civil rights laws
and then we can argue about that yeah so
within the book I mean I do have like a
political analysis I I do just I I you
know I say that this is what you do but
I think that it's you know quite doable
so you know when the Supreme Court ruled
on affirmative action um that got some
attention a lot of attention it wasn't
there wasn't protests in this you know
in the streets it wasn't like when
George Floyd got killed um it wasn't
even like dos where it had this
electoral backlash you know part of the
reason why because most of the public
agreed with actually um and a lot of
public well on the abortion issue the
left knows that most of the public
agrees with them and so they keep
harping on it and it's you know
politically advantageous for them to do
so um and so that was just you know that
was sort of more Salient than most
things that was you know getting rid of
affirmative action in universities a lot
of the stuff that I'm talking about is
very beneath the surface right the
disper impex does are you Define
discrimination based on the number of
people you you know the explicit
discrimination or you know uh the te you
know the tests are disp you know the
disparities based on tests you know if
people most people don't know what
disper impact was if they did know what
disper impact was they would probably be
horrified by it and think it was uh
Stupid um and so I think a lot of the
stuff is it's you know what liberals pay
attention to and what you know sort of
outrages people isn't always the most
important thing right so you could do
some things that are important and can
you know make a big difference but that
people really won't notice the way that
they notice a lot of uh other things um
well until the media blow it up I mean
there's that right the media going to
say but like I said I think they follow
public opinion and the even leftwing
opinion like so like abortion they will
you know keep harping on because they
think it can help Democrats and they can
win elections they want to they want to
run out affirmative action and make that
the biggest deal you know they've tried
to brainwash people all that stuff it
doesn't work you know people all think
it's messaging it's like no like the
public you know they're not they're not
they don't take the pro-life position
and they're not going to be for
affirmative action and like you know ra
you know the equity agenda you just
can't get them to do that not even
California not even Washington what they
vote for so they could they could freak
out but probably going to limit
themselves just because they you know
they're being strategic here or sort of
like you know sort of subconsciously
strategic about what helps liberals um
and at the same time they're just
there's just not an audience for a lot
of this you know sort of wokeness as law
um and so I do think this stuff is
doable um you know and so you know a lot
of it can be done through the executive
branch a lot of it can be done through
the courts the affirmative action that I
talked about in Government Contracting
that was an executive order um that
could be undone by executive order uh VI
rasabi I told him about this executive
order and he promised that on the first
day his office not just to me I mean
publicly uh that he would he would
repeal that it wasn't you know it wasn't
going get that much attention because
nobody even knows about affirmative
action in Government Contracting right
there's so many things that they could
be getting outreached about um and so
there's that you know there's the
disperate impact docr I mean it has to
go um you could do that that that was
not in the original Civil Rights Act I
mean it could be done through courts or
could through the executive branch and
then a lot of this stuff is sort of the
power of the purse stuff you know you
see um this is sort of realistic at the
federal level right now with the with
Biden an office but at the state level
you do see States getting rid of Dei
offices um you know it's it's been
happening in Iowa I've seen it happen in
Texas it happen in Florida uh and so a
lot of the Civil Rights stuff on the
universities came through the power of
the purse saying look we give all this
government money to you you do what I
want um you could do it in reverse too
and we've seen some states start to do
start to do that Richard sorry just to
finish on this point um a quick question
I have is particularly at the federal
level the stuff you're talking about I
mean you're a smart guy you're probably
not the only guy that's realized this is
going on how come Republican presidents
in the past haven't tackled these issues
in the way that you're Advocate yeah I
mean a lot of people you know like if
you go to sort
of yeah I I this is such an important
question and such a good question that I
don't that I that I have an entire
chapter uh in the book about like where
have Republicans been and I frame it in
exact that way the public is sort of
with you on this it's important it's a
big deal and so you know where Where
Have You Been um people don't I think
people what people don't realize is that
there really wasn't a conservative media
um until the late 1990s right um if you
look at the cover like 1980s Ronald
Reagan actually fought on this stuff he
tried to get rid of uh affirmative
action to Government Contracting he
tried to do some stuff that I describe
in the book on civil rights law to sort
of uh take the foot of the federal
government off of um off of the uh uh
off he actually vetoed a bill uh to
basically protect you know uh religious
liberty and basically being able to get
rid of a lot of this title n feminist
regulations away from universities it
got overridden and you look at the media
coverage at the time the media coverage
the only stories you could find are the
Washington Post New York timeses about
how this is just Republicans are racist
and Democrats are are not racist and so
there's no conservative media it's it's
completely there's a monopoly of
information in the late 1990s you get
Fox News um and then you have 2000s the
war on terror sort of dominates
everything this stuff has now been
around for 20 30 years so we've only had
like 25 years of like conservatives sort
of having like there's conservative
legal Scholars who've done a good a lot
of good work that I've cited them right
but they're not the people who are
getting you know the attention of the
Senators and the and the President right
um and so we've only had really like 25
years of any kind of real uh
conservative media to any substantial
degree um and you know a lot has been
going on in that 25 years um and this
stuff was in many cases DEC es old uh so
there you know they really you know you
sort of have to you know people people
forget I mean a lot of this stuff was
sort of live issues in the 1970s 1980s
it went around for a very long time um
and so I think now is the time to act on
it I just think that people sort of uh
you know people people sort of you know
underestimate how much like knowledge
and know knowledge can be sort of lost
if people don't pay attention to
something it just becomes part of the
status quo Richard would you not say
that it would need to be a very very
brave president to do this because if
you think how
charged literally every discussion is
now now people can almost come to blows
with a discussion about should men be
allowed to walk into a woman's toilet
and we're talking here about dismantling
civil rights laws I mean that is going
that could very well be a powder keg of
an issue you don't I mean you don't call
it dismantling civil rights laws you say
and this is true
you he's a political expert yeah M
that's what I do we're going to come out
dismantle civil rights slow P to the
Head yeah no you say go to the back to
which is actually true you say you go
back to the original intent of the Civil
Rights Act you're strengthening civil
rights all right like the people who
suit to get rid of affirmative action
they didn't call themselves you know the
anti-il rights Coalition they call
themselves you know students for Fair
admission admissions right um so yeah I
I don't you know like yeah Brave
president I don't know like like I mean
we have I mean Trump was a brave
president I mean he did a lot of things
that angered a lot of people a lot of
the time this stuff is a lot you know
less popular than a lot of the other
stuff he did um so it's doable I mean he
signed that executive order I mean the
sort of the closest analog to this is he
signed that executive order in the last
months of office after you saw Chris
rufo on Fox news that said um no more
critical race Theory trading in the
federal government get a little bit of
attention it wasn't the biggest Scandal
of his presidency but you know president
you know Republican presidents are
polarizing anyway they do stuff that
angers the media it's it's not you know
impossible to imagine Richard do you
think it might be that we've reached w a
lot of people term Peak woke and as a
result of reaching Peak woke this is a
much easier policy to implement or do
you think we haven't reached that point
yet we haven't reached the height of the
insanity yeah I mean I did you know I
did write an article on this I think
that sort of I I do think we you know it
depends on where you're looking so if
you're looking at universities or the
media um I think woke has been sort of
institutionalized and it's it's it's not
like it was in 2020 but it is I mean it
is sort of just you know it's in the
it's in The Ether now it's fundamental
to like what institutions are um as far
as the wider culture I do think we're
past Peak well I mean mostly because
things can't go on forever like you
can't maintain the frenzy of Summer 2020
you know indefinitely like you have to
go back to some kind of normaly um but
like you know Ethan Strauss has got a
good substack as a sports writer has
written about how basically the sports
coverage just went back to covering
sports like two three years ago it was
you go to the front page and half of it
is you know some kind of woke nonsense
they're still liberal but they're mostly
just covering Sports now um and I think
that's sort of a good bellweather to
where we are to where we are and so yeah
I mean I think that yeah we are in a
place where um you know I think that
people sort of you know there's been you
know people media figures you know
people in law and government I mean they
they' they've pushed back on it um I
think the ports of civil rights law is
like sort of like it's always it's sort
of like having a state religion it stays
Laten right so like in I want to make
sure in 15 20 years we don't have
another summer of 2020 the civil rights
law makes it very very easy to do that
because it's all there's always lawsuits
there's always bureaucracies around you
know if they go away you won't notice
that they go away but they just go away
and then we don't have a summer of 2020
again we don't have you know all these
crazy sort of initiatives uh so yeah I
do think overall we are probably past
Peak woke and yeah it's also a good it's
a good I mean it's a sometime might make
it harder because there's no uh there's
no um uh urgency it's just like oh the
problem solved itself but like no
institutions are still doing racial be
counting they're still relying on
dispert impact they're still doing
affirmative action so you got to keep
reminding people that it's actually you
know it's important to to you know to to
focus on these issues and to do
something about them the thing that I
always found very interesting is a role
of shareholders in this so for instance
you know all these shareholders with you
in who bought shares in huge companies
and then the performance of a said
company let's take Disney for example
because it has these just a random yeah
just a random just a random company
because it Embraces these polities and
policies and these ideologies suddenly
the profits go through the floor I would
always thought that there'd be a real
tension there with the shareholder
because surely they're
Furious well I mean maybe but remember
before Elon Musk bought Twitter you had
you had civil rights law you had sort of
his bullying from the government and you
also had the media which would you know
you can you stand up to Black Liv matter
they'll betray you as the Klux Clan and
is that good for shareholder value no I
think in a lot of cases they were
following their interest by just giving
in you know the mob comes and says nice
story you have there you know it be
terrible a shame if something happens to
it it's often rational to just give in
even though you would rather you know
you would rather ideally not have to pay
any kind of protection money um and so I
do you know I I do think this is cons I
do think what we've seen is sort of
consistent now with like you know now
with like uh social media changed and
some of the conservatives being you know
pushing back uh through the St through
the state governments um you know and
other and other means you know I do
think that there has been sort of a
shift in coprorate America so yeah I I
do think it all of this is consistent
with sort of a classic capitalist model
where you know businesses do what's in
their financial interest the the job of
sort of activists and people in politics
is to make their interest to to do the
right thing yeah and we saw that I mean
with Bud Light they went from Dylan mvan
to now advertising with the UFC that's
that's that's a shift isn't it
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy of course I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
I'm the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything thing Francis
remember what your lawyer said good
point you can trust expressvpn because
they don't sell your data to advertisers
they've even created software called
trusted server that means they can't
store any data at all expressvpn uses
lightweight a VPN protocol that makes
user speeds faster than ever expressvpn
is now blazingly fast you can watch HD
videos with zero buffering thousands of
pounds in legal fees the great thing
about expressvpn is that you don't need
any technical skills to set it up just
like Francis fire up the app and it's
one button to connect One Tap on a
button was all it needed for my entire
life to
disintegrate loads of people are saying
that expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals ra expressvpn as the
number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with Express
VPN
use our link
expressvpn.com trigger toay and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took
everything but listen um it's a great
book I really recommend people check it
out there's one other thing uh I wanted
to talk to you about before we we head
over to locals and ask you questions
from our audience um people when you
wrote the book and when you were gearing
up to promote it uh some some people in
the media uh came after you and sort of
did an expose on your past and uh you
were quite you had some extreme views in
the past that you've written about um
since and that I thought it was a very
interesting thing where someone a
someone in the public eye who did have
extreme views that were revealed they
came for you and they didn't manage to
cancel you but the other thing that I I
thought was interesting is well was that
you were someone who just owned the the
mistakes that they' made and kind of
described how you went from where you
were to where you are now can you tell
us a little bit about that because I
think that' be fascinating for people
yeah I mean it's interesting you know it
dropped it dropped about a month and a
half uh before my uh book came out and
this stuff was you know stuff that I'd
written 15 years ago I mean it's not I
don't stand by it I think it's you know
I think it's awful stuff and I think
people sort of and I was lucky I think
because I had um a body of work since
then where people can see that like
that's not how I think anymore at the
same s to interrupt just give us a
flavor of some of the things that you
were writing about back then and sort of
some of the views you held yeah I mean
so I you know I believed I believed in
basically a white identity politics um I
thought that you even though I'm Middle
Eastern I thought that this was sort of
maybe necessary to counteract um leftist
identity politics there was a sort of uh
you know you know you know like
immigration restrictionism uh on that
basis stuff about you know women
shouldn't vote and this and that and you
know which I you know I've denounced
explicitly even before this stuff came
out so you know basically like imagine a
right-wing um you know Anonymous poster
but you know uh you know a little bit
more sort not hard to imagine we see a
lot of those but what I'm curious about
and I know you've written about in your
substack is how you came to have those
ideas in the first place because frankly
let's be honest there's quite a lot of
people that are leaning in that
direction certainly online as you say
anonymously Etc so please understand I'm
not trying to make you look bad here I'm
just very curious to explore how you
come to that and then how you move out
of that that's very interesting to me
yeah yeah and and I did write an essay
you know explaining that so yeah it's of
course uh you know I appreciate you
asking um it's uh yeah I mean I think
you start out with I think this is where
where this is sort of my journey I think
it's a lot of people's Journey too is
that you see the mainstream media it and
you know institutions education system
are absolutely insane on some issues
right America is a white supremacist
Nation there are no differences between
men and women I didn't have to you know
I sometimes see people who read
scientific papers like look men are
stronger than women I'm like you had to
read scientific papers for just like the
moment I heard it I was just like you
know you watch the nature shows and they
show the male behaves like this and the
female behaves like this and it's like
where where does this stuff come from
and you know when I was in college I
would have like these cultural
anthropology courses and I remember just
questioning like the professor on this
you know this Assumption of like gender
blank sism and he just had nothing I
mean it was just really really bad and
so you start out with that like okay
people are lying to you in an extreme
absurd way you know it's not like
they're just the facts are a little bit
off it's like they're telling you the
sky is green um and then it becomes easy
to think all Society is corrupt you know
everything is false right I think people
like you know they get into like
revisionism about like World War II or
like they get into like antia or you
know anything people conspiracy theories
people will buy into anything because of
the because of just how crazy sort of
society is on race and gender and now
with gender identity I mean it's even
it's even it's even crazier um and I
think it's just sort of some part of it
is just sort of like a logical thing
where like people have been lying to me
so I'm just GNA think you know whoever
Anonymous person says on the internet
you know it's true part of it is just
emotional you become alienated from
society you become angry you see sort of
a lot of dysfunction and you see people
are lying to you about it um and you
sort of just take this you know
antagonistic view toward Society um and
then you uh yeah you it could drive some
people crazy um and I think what's you
know something a little bit different
for me is that I didn't become like a
leftist I still think Liberals are
absolutely crazy on Race on gender
issues um but you know I Grew Older and
smarter and thought more carefully about
it and wanted to give people
constructive solutions to do something
about it um and you know also my world
we sort of became less conspiratorial
over time as I did see you know sort of
the history of civil rights law just
more knowledge of where this stuff came
from out of a genuine interest in it um
and you know and then also observing
that a lot of times the non-mainstream
people you know the anonymous Twitter
accounts or whatever they're also crazy
they also believe things that are
obviously not true in many cases they're
you know worse than the mainstream media
um and so yeah I mean it's just having
that balance just knowing that they're
lying to you knowing what they're saying
is false but not going into sort of this
habit of you know all was talking about
them lying to you that's like the
default state of interacting with the
world and you know that's sort of of my
process and I hope that other people uh
who sort of know the left is crazy on
some issues you know I hope they could
sort of uh I hope they could take some
lessons from that I think the dangerous
thing about extreme ideologies where
right and left is that it co-ops people
but also it antagonizes others and in
many ways it's actually the people who
it antagonizes are even more dangerous
like people go to me you're worried
about woke people and I go well you know
I mean they're here to they're here to
stay and what they I'm don't agree a lot
of what they've done but I'm actually
far more worried about the backlash that
I see coming on the horizon than I am
about wug people if I'm
honest yeah I mean you know it's uh yeah
I mean the backlash is I mean I do think
that like you do see people who are on
the right who are like just they do
become like anti-democracy like it's
it's sort of a Trope that like you know
liberals just made this like no like a
lot of them do like
Putin like a lot of them sort of have a
grudging respect for the chines right um
a lot of them do just think democracy is
false so you're absolutely right you
know there is a there is a backlash that
can many cases be just as bad as what
it's fighting against yeah I sat next to
a guy at dinner a while ago who's like a
prominent writer here in the UK he was
telling me how China is more democratic
than the US and I was going mate just
like whatever you're reading stop
reading it CU your brain is is melting
here exactly perfect demonstration of
the point yeah you're absolutely right
but but it's also as well that you know
they people become more emboldened the
bigger the backlash grows yeah and and
and the thing that I find worrying as
well is that you know by deplatforming
these people what you're effectively
doing is you're giving these ideas a
kind of Glamour you can't listen to it
because you know this is this is so
dangerous and if you think about young
people like yourself at the
time that's kind we that could be
interpreted as dissident thought yeah
yeah and a lot of them have embraced
sort of the dissident thing right the
dissident sort of you know they call
themselves dissident writer or whatever
uh you know the problem with that is I
mean if to call yourself a just a
dissident and say that's your sort of
identity is like just as illogical
saying I'm a mainstream media kindy
whatever they I'm going to believe right
you'll be you'll end up just as stupid
in many ways worse because like you know
there's no accountability for like what
Anonymous people say online were in the
media like you know there's debate and
there's people go back and forth I mean
yeah you could find a dissident view
that China and Russia are more
democratic and you know Freer and better
countries you know than the than the
United States um it's uh yeah I think
it's just a cautionary tale of like you
know if you become you know anti-
wokness becomes you know goes too far
becomes part of your identity yeah
people we we we've got to lead people
away from that that's not a good place
to be yeah yeah I agree with you man and
obviously Francis and I have you know
people would say we're anti-woke because
we are anti-woke we've never made that
our identity particularly but it does
but we are
dissidents but I this isn't what
dissidents look like man but uh you know
the the thought that what I started to
notice with I mean Ukraine was a big one
for me but there was lots of others
where it's like oh you're not someone
who's just concerned about the fact that
the mainstream has gone bad which
it has you're you've got a form of like
oppositional Defiance disorder where
it's like whatever they say you pick the
opposite and that's the entire posture
towards the world that you have what I
uh Wonder not to get too personal with
you but I'm just curious
quite often I think uh moving from that
sort of extreme way of looking at the
world did you start to change how you
see the world because you maybe became a
bit happier in your life did you was
that part of it or am I projecting here
no I I think that is I mean I think that
is right I was sort of uh yeah I was
much less happy 15 years ago than I am
uh now and a lot of it was just sort of
you know regular self-improvement you
know getting in shape you know talking
to girls uh you know the stuff that
people uh you know the stuff that you
know your your uncle might you know tell
you might tell you to do yeah I think
that you can't really separate this
stuff I think that a lot of the wokeness
um you've probably seen the uh uh data
on wokeness and mental illness I mean
it's undeniably can you know there's a
connection there and just from being
around sort of uh you know sort of the
rightwing sort of dissident extremist
sphere uh you see there's something
similar going on you know that's that to
me is absolutely clear from my
experiences the the thing that I find
frustrating with should we just call
them this dissident Community is they
constantly attack wug people and they
say oh they're losers you know they have
a victim mindset well mate you've got a
victim
mindset yes it's often it's often uh
it's often you know it's often just as
bad or or Worse right like you'll see
you know they'll see they'll say oh you
know like there a lot of you know it's
like you know people still get married
people still have kids people still buy
houses I mean life is continuing right
it's there's not this apocalyptic
dystopia that people on the online R
imagine yeah we have problems but you
know you deal you think about them you
put them in perspective and you think of
like you know smart policy solutions to
to deal with them that's that's the
healthy grownup way to think about these
things Richard on one quick topic before
we move to locals because you mentioned
being from the Middle East where where
in the Middle East are you from uh my
dad is a Palestinian Christian and my
mom is a a Jordanian Catholic I throw
the religion in there because people of
course want to know for I can't see you
guys by the way you guys are
frozen you're Frozen for us as well
Elliot now I see there we go yeah there
you go okay perfect cool so uh one quick
topic before we move to locals and do
questions from our audience with your
middle eastern background um how would
you solve it um you've been going hard
at it on Twitter which I'm enjoying you
you love trolling people uh and I love
watching I love trolling people I love
watching other people trolling people
it's it's a past time of mine um but you
are I have not seen anybody go harder on
the Palestinians than you let's put it
that way so what is kind of your take on
the Middle East and and the conflict
there in the events of last six weeks
yeah so I have a essay on my substack
that's going to be I've written a few
essays but I have another one where it's
just going to be talking about uh how we
understand anti-Semitism so we or
anti-israeli sentiment so a lot of
people they think you know um look I you
know I'll put it this way I've been
reading a lot of and listening to a lot
of sort of liberals talk about the
current Israeli Palestinian conflict and
you know it's amazing they don't deny
they don't deny what Hamas is they can't
deny it they don't even like they don't
even have a suggestion of who you would
talk to on the Palestinian side to ever
get peace it's just like don't fight you
know don't fight the war hope you know
give them Aid like don't like go to
don't go to war war after this you know
terrorist attack that killed 200 people
you know like a medieval raid like took
off women and children uh back to Gaza
and you know there's not even like a
hint of a suggestion and so you know
it's there's there's G there has to be
an Israeli response I mean Israel is
threaten long term they're having
Rockets throw at you know lobbed at them
from the north and from the uh from the
south um you know there's no you know
there's technology that develops over
time where the rocket technology and the
Drone technology potentially gets better
there's a terrorist organization you
know it's basically a state um Gaza I
mean it runs its own Affairs um that is
dedicated to Israel's destruction
doesn't even pretend to want like a
two-state solution or anything and so
like you know this is you know the the
framework here is not like you know a
criminal organization or like a
terrorist organization on the other side
the framework here should be you know
the threat from Germany or Japan in
World War and to that like to the US or
Britain like I don't think Germany or
Japan was as threatening as as Israel or
as the as Gaza is to the Israelis
because they're right next to them
there's population there's you know
there's a you know there's sort of a uh
you know there's already you know
Rockets there's we a different level of
Technology um and so you know and
there's you know a commitment to their
destruction in the way like Japan didn't
want to you know necessarily destroy the
US that wasn't like their you know part
of their you know governing ideology um
and so Israel has to you know fight I
think Israel has to fight this war to
win um in the long run it'll be better
for the Palestinian people if they're
not
you know ruled by these terrorists I you
know I think that the idea of open uh
pressuring the world to open up refugees
open up to refugees and you know it
could be the Arab states it could be
European States it could be you know
whoever I mean anywhere they would
anywhere would be better than Gaza right
under Hamas um and being you know
constantly uh you know people call it an
open air prison cap so I think that I
think that there should be sort of I
think Israel has to just do what it
needs to do to ensure its own security
and I think that there is no optimistic
scenario of like what Gaza looks like
with the Palestinians living there and
you know when when we have these tragic
situations we all we often on almost
every other case we accept the idea that
people should become refugees and go
start somewhere else because it's too
you know it's too the situation is too
tragic it's too terrible where they are
right now it's better for them in the
long run uh so I think that should be
sort of the goal here um it doesn't seem
like uh you know it doesn't seem like a
lot of the people in the region agree
because you know they want to they care
about the Palestinian cause and a lot of
people don't want the refugees um but I
think that's the that's the sort of
that's the path to a long-term Humane
solution to all of this and what do you
make of the argument I mean I heard John
uh May shimer recently saying that the
reason Hamas uh attacked on October 7th
is that uh the their resistance force
fighting against Israeli occupation
fighting against Israeli oppression and
as long as Israel uh continues to have
this right-wing government that is being
uh controlled by far right for forces
within Israel that believe in a single
state solution where Israel controls
everything they believe in Greater
Israel that's why Hamas lashed out and
they'll continue to lash out as long as
the Palestinian people are oppressed
well I mean it depends on how you def I
mean I mean it's true in a sense and
that like it's because there's a dispute
between the Palestinians and Israelis
and they're oppressed but what does
oppressed mean I think that to to the to
the a lot of the Palestinian people into
Hamas and Gaza oppression means what
happened in 1948 what's happened in 1967
right and so yes they're oppressed they
see the existence of the Jewish State
itself as a source of Oppression so it's
true if you gave up on the idea of
Jewish of a Jewish State now like this
idea that like mer you know you could
probably you could have peace of course
now this idea that um you know I haven't
heard I haven't heard mim's opinion on
this but you know taking your word is
that's that's what he you know that's
what he's saying here we can we can uh
use that as an argument um the idea that
there's a difference between like a
right-wing Israeli government versus a
left-wing Israeli government and that's
going to make Hamas moderate and less
likely to attack you know Hamas itself
doesn't say that I mean ham you know
it's is a very big projection onto them
it's not like oh man Nyah who won the
election if you know if it been you know
the labor party if you know the the
leftist had won we'd be you know we'd be
we we'd get to a two-state solution
there's not even like a hint of like
pretending to think like this right um
so I don't know like what evidence it
would take to get people to just see
that like look Hamas and you know the
Palestinian people in general you know
the majority of them um don't want
Israel to exist um and their you know
political and military actions are
consistent with with that belief and
their words I mean and and how they act
I just don't see what the evidence is
for the opposite perspective it's a
sensible perspective I mean like you
know um you could in some you know in
some uh you know the US left Vietnam and
you know the Vietnamese you know left
the Americans alone and you know they
were was it an ideology of destroying
America um from the Viet Kong but uh in
this case I just don't see what the
evidence is for it I mean it's a great
point and also as well I just it's that
classic thing where people just want a
simple solution to a very very complex
problem they yeah they don't want
trade-offs they want to think like you
must if you're you know it's like you
know it's like if the if the
Palestinians are angry it must be you
have to be sort of nicer to them or be
more Humane and then they're going to be
less angry and you're going to achieve
your security it would be nice you know
you see these ideas like oh don't attack
the people of AA don't kill a lot of
Civilian just go like kill the leaders
of Hamas it's like you think like people
weren't like nobody's tried that you
think Israel did think okay oh just kill
the leader no they're they're in
hospitals they're they're you know they
put uh they put guns under the beds of
their you know of their children right
they live in these uh they in these
areas because that's their hope that's
their strategy for fighting right so
they're not making it easy for you
they're not going off to a field
somewhere and saying come fight us and
you can you know now drone us or meet us
in the field they're doing they're
specifically you know playing to these
human rights sentiment um in order as
part of their strategy because that's
what they have they're not the they're
not the stronger side um so yeah I just
think you know just looking at sort of
the laughter the so-called propiece side
um in all this It just strikes me as
completely unrealistic and Richard thank
you so much uh for coming on the show
the final question is always the same
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be yeah so in uh you know in the United
States we have a sort of a a budget um
uh you know an apocalypse Upon Us in 10
15 years um the population is getting
older the if you look at the percentage
of federal budget going to old people
through Social Security and Medicare
it's very high and these people are
aging and about 2033 the money runs out
we're either going to have to cut
spending to old people and even like
Rich old people get the same benefits
that you know poor poor old people do or
we're going to have to sort of raise
taxes uh and become a uh a Euro welfare
state but without even the welfare it's
just all going to go to old people right
um and so there's a guy named Brian rle
who I have my own podcast at cspi
center.com um I just talked to him about
this the other week um and yeah this is
the next 105 years I think this is going
to really determine uh you know the
future of sort of the American standard
standard of living so I I encourage
people to read up and think about the
entitlements question because it's it's
coming for us in the next 10 15 years
all right we need a call of old people
there we go Richard see you are
woke Richard great book origins of work
I recommend everybody it out to get your
take on it we're going to head on over
to locals where we're going to ask you
questions from our supporters that
they've submitted uh so we'll see you
there appreciate it thanks
guys in recent years the woke mob and
anti-racist authors have attempted to
say that only white people can be racist
how can a white person legally complain
against something that with modern
language rebranding no longer exists
when applied to
[Music]
them